First, you really need all your features to be
available and fully usable on the mobile version. If you
try to guess what content or features your users
won't miss on the mobile, you'll probably get it wrong.
It might seem logical, right up until the point
where I try to browse store inventory for my mobile
device, only to find that feature is not availbale.
Secondly, with two apps or sites, there's a natural tendency
to focus on one or the other and to
get out of sync between them. Maintaining two separate applications
and keeping them fundamentally the same is hard to
do. And finally, there's the problem that it's difficult to
identify when you really want the mobile version. My
tablet for example has nearly as big a screen as
my laptop, and it's actually higher resolution than my
laptop. Mobile design is actually more of a spectrum that
spans all the way from low-resolution devices up into
desktop design. At the very least, there are three
simple rules if you want to offer a mobile-only
site. First, you want to make sure a user
can still get to the full site from the mobile site if they want to, in case you
forgot any features. Secondly, you should but canonical URL
in meta-information. This is commonly done for search engine optimization,
but it's also important to keep your
mobile site and your desktop site together. Finally,
if someone links to a specific page on
your desktop site, you shouldn't transfer them to
your top-level mobile page. You need to
transfer them to that specific page or its
equivalent, on the mobile site. It's really frustrating
when you get redirected to the top-level page.